interdire les expulsions locatives en
2021 dans toute la france c'est la
proposition de la maire de vénissieux et
vice-présidente de la métropole de lyon
dans un courrier adressé au premier
ministre jean castex michèle picard
montent au créneau pour venir en aide
aux plus démunis
alors que la crise sanitaire continue de
battre son plein je trouve que mettre
des gens à la rue sans relogement c'est
inadmissible dans une société comme la
nôtre et encore plus aux crises
sanitaires
parce que on sait que les gens qui sont
à la rue basson sont encore plus c'est
encore plus fragilisé la crise sanitaire
a développé aussi une crise économique
une crise sociale sans nom ce qui fait
que du cours va avoir de plus en plus de
gens et on le voit le secours populaire
la fondation abbé-pierre toutes ces
associations attire l'attention des
pouvoirs publics sur le sur la précarité
la pauvreté qui s'accentue de jour en
jour même constat du côté de
l'association réseau d'alerté de
solidarité
cette association de vénissieux vient en
aide aux personnes affectées par les
ordres d'expulsion depuis 1997
son président andré mazuir est
catégorique la crise a empiré la
situation de ceux qui étaient déjà en
difficulté la crise économique et la
crise sociale
elle arrivait de toute façon n'était en
2019 et il y avait des prémices pour que
cette crise allait claque la crise
sanitaire qui arrivait en 2020 a rajouté
je rajoutais donc de la difficulté pour
les familles et a permis effectivement
que les choses se compliquent pour un
certain nombre de familles prévue pour
le 1er avril 2021 le gouvernement à
repousser la fin de la trêve hivernale
des expulsions locatives au 1er juin
pour permettre aux familles les plus
vulnérables d'affronter une crise non
seulement sanitaire mais aussi
économique et social